I hate intros a sentence of a bookworm
season 1 episode 1 we kick things off
with the introduction of the main
character mine who has a deep love for
books the high priest Ferdinand puts her
to sleep so that he can enter her mind
to see her past and why she loves books
so much mine used to be known as moto to
Verano from another world
she loved reading in her past life but
then was crushed by a pile of books as
she's dying she wishes that she can read
all kinds of books in her next life when
she wakes up she's the girl mine who is
in bed with the fever
we then me Ewa who is mine's mother and
even though she talks in two different
language mine can understand her soon
after we meet her older sister in Tully
who has to break the news to her that
they don't have any books few days go by
as she's getting acclimated in her new
life and she decides to go to the market
with epital look for a book as they're
walking to the market she learns about
her father
Gunther is one of the gatekeepers in the
medieval age city she suddenly looks for
books as they walk around the market and
comes across one in a glass case at one
of the stalls she asked the owner if she
could hold it but he tells her that only
Nobles are allowed to handle books
because of how rare they are in the last
scene she decides if she can't buy any
books then she's just gonna have to make
some for herself
episode 2 the next day Gunther forgot a
package at home so mine and totally go
to take it to him well heading there
they run into some boys they know in bay
looks and route the three boys help them
get to their father since mine is still
weak from her fever we learned that
Ralph is crushing on totally as they
send off some flirty vibes towards one
another
what's also seems to like mine and she
seems to be enjoying the attention know
how old she was in her former life but I
have a feeling this is illegal when they
get to their dad we meet Oh Tove who
learns about her desire to read and
write jump ahead a bit where odo gives
mine a small chalkboard called a slate
where she can practice writing and
learning the new symbols in the language
episode three at this point she's now
been mine for two months and winter has
set in mine is trying to find new ways
to make paper and is waiting for spring
to try and make clay tablets where you
get some filler concept when Tully and
Gunther picked Peru's which are fruit
and mine gets the idea to turn the pulp
- pancakes calling them Peru cakes
everything seems to be going well but
mine slate pencils keep running out and
she needs a way to write so she makes a
deal with odo to get her more in
exchange for the pencils she agrees to
help him with calculations that he has
to do for his job yep so for mine share
x' with the family her desire to go to
the forest and find clay so that she can
make tablets to ride on they say that
she can't yet because her body isn't
strong enough so she has to find a way
to get the exercise she needs to make it
to the forest she becomes Otto's
assistant and travels to the gate where
he works so that she can get the
exercise and eventually build up her
stamina to get to the forest she can't
officially be his assistant because
she's too young so as a cover she goes
to class with older boys to learn to
write he eventually the frequent
commutes make her stronger and she
finally goes to the forest after
multiple trips she is finally able to
make clay tablets with the help of what
she uses the tablets to write the
stories that her mom tells her while
she's sick so that she won't forget them
yep so five mine gets the idea to make
hair ornaments for Thole in celebration
of her baptism the hair ornaments are a
huge hit because nobody's ever thought
to do something like that since her
sister is now an apprentice seamstress
mine is given a knife to be the house
helper she decides to use the knife to
make wooden tablets instead of clay
tablet well it's offers to help her in
exchange for her setting up a meeting
with odo so that he can learn more about
becoming a traveling merchant they mix
suit with clay to make pencils however
when she goes to retrieve her wooden
planks she learned that her mother used
them for firewood mine gets extremely
stressed out over this and starts to
glow soon falling unconscious
yep zone six job had just been in mind
prepares Lutz for his meeting with odo
by washing his hair with her homemade
shampoo to make him look presentable
odo had also brought a man named Bano to
the meeting who is a city merchant and
used to be a travelling trader Meno is
intrigued by how they got their hair so
clean but mine doesn't want to give up
anything for free odo tries to convince
Lutz not to become a traveling merchant
because he will lose his citizenship he
decides he doesn't want to give up his
citizenship and is instead determined to
help mine make all of her inventions
knowing that Benno is a merchant mine
tells him that she has the idea to make
paper out of plants he is of course
skeptical but she promises a prototype
before her baptism and he agrees to
sponsor her if she succeeds mine and
let's begin their project to make paper
but they run into a snag when they need
nails
odo offers up some nails in exchange for
her washing his wife's hair who was
named Karina and is also the sister of
Benno in the last scene Beto discusses
with odo that mine might have a disease
called the devouring and could die from
it episode 7 mine and let's meet with
bono who is upset that they went to odo
instead of himself for help with the
nails they make a new agreement for bono
to supply them with whatever they need
to make the paper and in exchange he
gets the rights to mines shampoo as
they're working Lutz grows more
suspicious that mine might be someone
else entirely because of her complex
ideas and thinking jump ahead a little
bit and we learn more about the
devouring from Benno
it occurs when common our children
develop mana but have no way to extract
it and it eventually devours and kills
them soon after Beto secures mine and
Lutz a new workshop but mine isn't
allowed to do any of the heavy lifting
because she's still under severe stress
from her fevers episode 8 mine and let's
get situated at their new workshop that
bento had acquired for them they then
employ the work of lumbers and craftsmen
to make the tools they need to make the
new paper once they have their supplies
they head into the forest to make up the
prototypes mine comes across a dangerous
plant called a trombe aid that
continuously grows and kills all of its
surroundings in a panic Lutz and his
friends have to hurry to chop it up
before it can spread this can
Bentley gives them a different kind of
substance to try making the paper out of
later we learned that Lutz had grown
even more suspicious about my not being
herself and finally confronts her about
it figuring she can't hide it forever
she tells him the truth about her former
life at first he's extremely upset and
what's the old mine so she offers to let
the fever consume her and die if that's
what he would prefer he decides that
even though she isn't the mind that he
used to know she's still been her for
around a year now and they've made a lot
of good memories so he doesn't want to
lose them once they finish they bring
the prototype paper to Beto who is
pleased with the product so he makes
Lutz and mine his apprentices yep so
high to become official mine and lots
have to become members of the merchants
guild Benno takes them to meet Gustav to
get them approved in their membership
Brno and Gustav are kind of rivals so
they have to offer to make his daughter
mines hair ornaments for her baptism
after settling on this deal the two
become members of the merchants guild we
then meet Frieda who is the daughter of
Gustav that they need to make the hair
ornament for once business is concluded
the three of them get to talking about
the devouring Frieda is also suffering
from the devouring and states that it
cannot be cured on the other hand it
can't be contained by staying motivated
and not losing heart episode 10 coming
up on the one-year mark mine is again
stuck in bed with her fever and feels
like it's getting a lot worse lately
once she's feeling better
benno employs her aid helping with the
shampoo recipe because his men can't
seem to get it right in exchange for the
information Beto agrees to pay a
ridiculous price mine is confused as to
why he's offering up so much money and
he tells her that it's for when she
needs to buy medication for the
devouring as the devouring seems to be
getting worse and worse mine thinks of
more consumable products to sell when
she suddenly collapses in the last scene
episode 11
mine was taken to Frieda who had a magic
bracelet that absorbs enough of her mana
to let mine live the bracelet breaks
afterwards and Frieda tells her the only
way to get more magic items like this
one is entering an agreement with a
noble Frieda had agreed to become a
Nobles mistress after her
of age ceremony and tells mine that she
will have to do something similar in
order to survive
she also speculates that mine has one
year left to live before she will need
another magic item to absorb more of the
mana as it turns out she ends up having
to pay Gustav most of the money that she
had gotten from Benno
in exchange for use of the magic
bracelet later when she is able to
return home she tells her family that
she isn't cured and only has a year left
to live she also tells them that she
doesn't want to have to rely on a noble
and she'd rather die with her family
than be taken away somewhere else
episode 12 job passed another winter and
mine decides to end her apprenticeship
with Benno and sells him the rights to
the paper what's on the other hand is
determined to become a merchant so he's
continuing his apprenticeship under
Benno mine is focused on securing enough
money for her family before she dies so
she sells cooking recipes with sugar to
freedom yeah we're gonna jump ahead a
bit more to mines baptism with her and
what's going along with other children
to the city's temple well there she
laughs hysterically at their traditions
and collapses which is pretty
disrespectful but they think she's ill
so they rush her off to rest after a
while she tries to head back but gets
lost and comes across a library in the
temple Olli clergy are allowed to enter
the library so she meets with the high
bishop to get access to the library he
requests a donation so she promises one
large gold coin which is the highest
currency she is also required to get her
parents permission but even if they say
no she still gets permission to read the
books whenever she wants yep zone 13
when she returns home mine tells her
family about wanting to become a
priestess at the temple Gunther is
outraged and says that only orphans
joined the church and have to stay there
not knowing this mine returns to the
temple to turn down the offer when she
meets the high priest from episode 1
Ferdinand the two of them end up reading
scriptures until the high priest returns
when the priests find out she has the
Devourer rings they bring out a magic
rail that glows red when mine touches it
upon seeing this they request to meet
with her parents so that they can
convince them to let her join the temple
after the meeting blood stakes mine -
Benno who explains more about the
situation the priests have become desk
for mana because they don't have enough
due to conflicts in the government by
making an arrangement with them she
could get access to the books while also
draining her mana allowing her to
survive the devouring mana also suggests
making a magic contract with him and
Lutz so that she can still make contact
with them while she's at the temple wine
then goes to register at the guild to
create a constant supply of income for
her and Ben owes profits
what's his sad that they can no longer
make books together but mine informs and
that she hasn't given up on her dream
and she will still need his help in the
future episode 14 minor question the
negotiation with the priests hoping to
secure being treated as a noble
continuing to live at home keeping her
studio that Vento gave her all in
exchange for money and her mana when
they arrived to the meeting the high
priest realizes that they aren't wealthy
after learning this his attitude
completely changes and he starts talking
down to them and ordering that they give
mine to the temple after refusing the
high priests orders she be taken by
force and temple guards attacked them
Gunther fights back against the guards
so the high priest states that he's to
be executed this triggers mine and she
begins to glow and attacks the high
priest with her mana Ferdinand has to
step in and concert down so that they
can have an actual negotiation as they
were promised he explains that mine was
using something called the crushing
which is when a victim of the devouring
loses control of their emotions
Ferdinand gains a new found respect for
mine when he learns about how she's been
staying alive and refuses to be chained
to her Noble so he agrees to the
conditions and makes mine a member of
the temple and in the last scene they
return home to an emotional reunion with
Tully and Lutz I'm going to be doing the
next season and you can find that on the
left side whenever I'm finished with
them or you can check out all of the
ascendance of a bookworm recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
weeks of the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outros
you